hagamos la siguiente multiplicación 3
por 60 esto lo puedes ver como 60 tres
veces entonces esto sería igual a 60 más
60 más 60 y lo puedes hacer en tu cabeza
puedes pensar esto en tu cabeza y
entonces sería 60 más 60 es igual a 120
más 60 es igual a 180 y listo
terminaste a otra manera de pensar en
esto sería ok
veamos 3 por 60 es lo mismo que 3 por 60
es lo mismo que 6 por 10 entonces 6 por
10 y tienes 3 por 6 por 10 y cuando
multiplicas tres números así no importa
el orden en el cual los multiplique es
puedes multiplicar el 3 por 6 esto es
igual a 18 por el 10 esto simplemente es
igual a 180 ajá 18 con un cero y listo
esto es por lo tanto igual a 180 y
terminaste entre más lo practiques te
darás cuenta que que podrás hacerlo da
silva por ejemplo
por 6 es igual a 18 pero tienes un 0
entonces sería igual a 180 la misma
respuesta sale hagamos otro ejemplo vale
entonces ok vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
que te parece
aunque el 50 por 7 50 por 7 si quieres
poner pausa al vídeo inténtalo y después
sigues con el vídeo verás que llegamos a
la misma respuesta entonces 50 por 7 hay
distintas maneras de pensar en esto una
de ellas podrías sumar 57 veces pero
tardaría mucho por ejemplo 50 más 50 más
50 más 50 más 50 más 50
y mil años después falta que otros
cincuenta entonces mil años después
tendrías 50 más 50 y 100 más 50 150 200
250 300 y 350 puedes hacerlo así o
puedes hay una manera más sencilla es un
misterio pero te lo diré es un secreto
entonces puedes darte cuenta que el 50
es lo mismo que que 5 por 10 ajá 10 por
5 por 7 y el orden en el cual
multiplicas no importa podemos
multiplicar 5 por 7 primero hagamos esos
5 por 7 es igual a 35 y tenemos este 10
entonces 10 por 35
eso es igual al 35 y 10 entonces esto
estoy aquí es igual a 35 y le agregamos
ese 0 le ponemos ese 0 lo voy a poner el
mismo color entonces es igual a 350
también puedes observar este 5 y
multiplicar 5 por 7 es igual a 35
y no olvidar que ese 5 no es un 5 es un
50 entonces multiplicas el resultado por
10 agregando simplemente un 0 y ya está
entonces 50 por 7 es igual a 350